gta 6 is officially in development call
of duty has teased a new generation and
more
rockstar games has officially confirmed
that the next grand theft auto game is
in development and it's not just getting
started either as rockstar said in a
blog post that the new project is well
underway whether or not the new game is
called gta 6 or something else entirely
remains to be seen
this studio did not reveal any specifics
about the new game which is rumored to
have a fortnight style evolving map of
some sort presumably the new game is
being developed by multiple rockstar
studios as the company has done for some
of its big releases like red dead
redemption 2 most recently while
rockstar isn't ready just yet to divulge
specifics on the next gta the company
said its general philosophy with new
games is to significantly move beyond
what it achieved before which may be a
big fee considering the unprecedented
longevity of gta 5.
google has reportedly changed the
purpose and branding of stadius
technology in order to shop the
platform's streaming capabilities to
other partners the platform streaming
technology is under a new name google
stream
in a report from business insider people
familiar with the plans say that google
has shifted priorities from negotiating
blockbuster third-party titles to
securing deals with companies google
reportedly pitched its technology to
bungie for the studio's own streaming
platform and the talks made considerable
progress while bungie will continue to
support stadia it's unclear how sony's
purchase of bungie this week would
impact the talks with google google has
also spoken with capcom to run demos for
new titles utilizing its technology for
example google managed to successfully
pitch its stadia technology to a t where
customers were able to stream batman
arkham knight directly from their web
browser these types of collaborations
line up with google's announcement early
last year that it was shutting down its
internal first party studios and
shifting the priority for stadia to
steadily releasing titles from
independent developers stadia still has
over 200 games and is said to be
releasing over 100 more in the next year
so while the focus may be shifting there
still looks to be no shortage of beams
on the way for stadia users
call of duty vanguard has only been out
a few months but infinity ward is
wasting no time teasing its own game
which is expected to arrive this year in
very vague turns the modern warfare
studio posted a very short message that
is sure to get the community in a
collective investigation to uncover its
secrets with just two lines the official
infinity war twitter account confirmed a
new generation of call of duty would be
coming soon and this isn't a wendy's
reference it's a sign for fans to stay
alert for more news the new game is
expected to launch in 2022 following
activision blizzard's annual release
cycle whenever it says release it will
still be available on playstation
consoles this sounds from infinity
ward's tweet that the game may not
release on xbox one or ps4 but microsoft
gaming ceo phil spencer has confirmed he
wants to keep the series available on
non-xbox systems and microsoft's
purchase of activision blizzard is still
pending regulatory approval the next
three games in the series will
reportedly still be on playstation with
the future after that being unclear
so if infinity war does make the next
modern warfare and potentially a new war
zone what changes would you like to see
from war zone pacific and vanguard let
me know in the comments and of course as
always leave a like subscribe and have a
wonderful weekend we'll see you later
[Music]